due to a large influx of fake weapons we
had to redo this beautiful weapon rack
wall that we've had so gonna go across
down here we're going to do a second
rack across here and then we're going to
save this piece of mortgage shifted up
and over for some of the other items
more took that in the Edit draw me like
one of your french guns now I'm pulling
incredibly large nails that have been
hammered over like crazy back out of
these boards because we recycle ran dope
Oh always here to clean up your mess
Carmichael so no idea what's in this
let's find out I don't oh my god are you
serious
this is one of those like portable
gaming sets you put like your console in
here was this just like sitting and here
we have two I assume this will work just
fine with like a ps4 or something is
there like a battery do you have to like
plug it in power fuzz ask Nikko bettyp I
can be like oh yeah yeah we've had that
you know you know what these are
yeah they're our suitcases that it's
supposed to fit Xbox and they can with
the screen inside how long have we had
these I'm serious from years I don't
know it turns out you know we hook our
Xbox is up to TVs and we don't use them
for mobile gaming
that's what phones are for okay yes you
do plug this into power yeah it needs to
be plugged in so it's kind of useless it
does have a cool little HDMI cable
though this is actually probably more
useful than anything else in this
treasure yeah found it
you